part one part one sending this movie for
officially kicking off Hollywood's
fascination with splitting up movie
adaptations of final novels in a series
goddammit childhood is not from birth to
a certain age are we still freaking
talking do we need to know Bella's inner
thoughts anymore after three
motherfucking movies oh this wedding
invitation makes me so mad I'm gonna
drop it here in the ring so we will get
soaked
so soaked oh yeah that reminds me my
shirt it's too come on even when reading
his daughter's wedding invitation this
asshole has to have a beer handy also
they're getting married the hell
happened in that last movie again oh god
I don't really care I've been breaking
them in for three days Jase go barefoot
yeah it's either high heels or going
barefoot there certainly isn't any other
way to get married we'll be perfect
we'll be cuts from invited guests
receiving invitations straight to the
wedding day like that isn't done five
months ahead of time character in the
movie openly mocks all the directors who
took on Twilight films ello curry it's
bad luck by seeing the director of Snow
White in the huntsmen before the wedding
wedding Eve and Bella still has a huge
lamp problem one year turned on one here
turned off a string on the wall turned
off then we cut to this shot to see one
lamp on and an entire string of lights
on as well what is this girl's issue
with light sources this and checking
somewhere outside my own shoes vampire
puns also Edwards vampy sense is
tingling his skin is twinkling and I
think I'm gonna head to the bathroom for
a little tinkling so for a while I went
off on my own I wanted to know how it
felt to hunt so I was definitely
watching the Bride of Frankenstein
because that's a popular horror movie
that makes sense for the Twilight
narrative I definitely didn't watch a
night at the Opera over the 39 steps
because the Marx Brothers and Hitchcock
also Edward waits until literally the
night before the wedding to tell his
bride whatever scandal his story this is
I've already stopped paying attention to
it also wasn't Edward changed in 1918 so
he decided to rebel from Carlyle after
17 years as a vampire or did the
filmmakers just want to use Bride of
Frankenstein so bad they didn't get no
theatre staff appears to be working
today in 1935 those were the days when
everything pretty much ran it's up other
than that I come monsters Looby
justifies all the killing Edward has
ever done by delivering the caveat that
they all deserve to die god forbid he
killed any innocent people to make his
character just the slightest bit
interested also Dexter Edward is way
better story than Twilight
but is given 30 seconds of time while
the rest of it is approximately 10 hours
buttons
raisa stay tied nice so who I was you've
been through so much as a couple that I
can't believe this story was withheld
until now unless it's just because there
needed to be some new revelation in the
fourth Twilight to alleviate writer's
block
II know I can do this what be a vampire
can't anyone do that what does this
sentence even mean Jesus skipped vampire
hijinks editor accidentally cuts
American Beauty into this movie in
Bella's dream pre wedding her father was
a mere guest rather than walking her up
the aisle or giving her away at the
altar
Breaking Dawn Part 1 is like the seventh
season of a TV show that used to rule
the ratings but started to decline so
they plan a wedding episode despite
ratings for sweeps week and something
old besides your brother and now I get
to see why they divorce before the first
movie even came out fun Edward and Bella
somehow managed to book the super
popular wedding spot wooded area of a
million hanging angelic white flowers
and beautifulness where it has it they
were competing with Mark Zuckerberg for
this booking and one out at the last
second when he decided to just have his
own forest planet he thought I was gonna
be showing just she is not pregnant
okay who else gets married at 18 Anna
Kendrick is all the following things
here in the scene hot correct
inappropriate judgmental selfish and hot
ready well either the entire audience
can hear them from that distance or else
this wedding ceremony somehow gave a
silent cue to attendees to stand for the
imminent bride arrival also it then
takes two minutes of actual film time to
show Bella walk down the aisle just
don't never accept any of the previous
sixteen years of your life when I was a
total deadbeat alcoholic distant father
fellas dress is such that it makes the
high heeled training earlier in the
movie even dumber because nobody could
even see that anyway why is mom seated
right next to her ex-husband where's the
minor league baseball boyfriend from the
first movie damn I was just starting to
like that guy they choose much like real
weddings I wish I hadn't been invited to
this it was at this point in the
ceremony that Rupert Sanders stood up
and said I have nothing to declare right
now but I think many of you may find me
reprehensible a year from now
movie cut out the part where every
single wedding guest had an objection to
this Union a scene which was probably
amazing but was cut out strictly for
that reason Edwin Miller's wedding kiss
lasts the whole goddamn day also
seriously a standing ovation for the
18-year old getting married to the guy
most people here think is 17 but it's
actually 110 well I plan on giving girl
well I am not surprised to hear you say
that dad who always has a beer in his
hand anyway thank you grace isn't in
some convoluted plot involving being
taken in the scene 90 seconds of mostly
inappropriate toasts montage Jacob how
the fuck you know who that is a shirt
wearing distance yes
your alternate lover just outside the
reception of your wedding to a dude I
fucking hate also it's part one of a
popular book series adaptation so of
course time to make time for best
friends dancing to do that and to latex
to me clothes
this is exactly what my college
girlfriend said to me after a
particularly real crying in formalwear
and promising yourself forever to my
sworn enemy
yeah this is a utopian image right here
didn't really want to spend my honeymoon
writhing in pain who says you have to
honeymoon directly after the wedding I
can't get changed into a vampire and
then have the honeymoon after you've
calmed down the power of lady boners
causes the stupidest plot development
ever and we're gonna have to suffer
through two movies because of it no you
can't do this
the emotional control of these assholes
is hepatitis C for the plot this easily
could have been a calm discussion about
how vampire boning could kill her and
the supernatural world would flip it
instead Jacob can't control his wolf
temper it's been four minutes since I've
written to sin about this movie I think
it's either because I fell asleep or
nothing happened in those four minutes
anyway I think I'll just add a soon
because this movie is definitely
representative of sloth
[Music]
oh shut your fucking whining Jacob
vampire movie just can't resist stomping
a bit more on the religious folk among
us all so I guess the metaphor here is
that Bella is Jesus sacrificing her
virginity for the sake of wait and if
thirty minutes of waiting weren't enough
how about thirty minutes of a honeymoon
that's exciting right with this movie
being pg-13 I bet the sex will be more
amazing than anything we saw on Finding
Nemo this newlywed bride didn't shave
her legs until arriving at the honeymoon
suite and hey I'm all for women doing
whatever they want with their leg hair
but she clearly thinks shaved it's the
way to go so I'm sending her for waiting
until now to do something about her leg
hair situation she got married with
stubble the sex is not more amazing than
anything we saw on Finding Nemo also
vampire human sexual attention waits
until the fourth goddamn movie to even
remotely relieve said sexual tension
yeah well you should see what her vagina
looks like I can't tell you how sorry um
didn't you already know what the risks
of vampire human coitus was going to be
before you acted upon said coitus I mean
is this even an issue this seems like
made up both to make the movie longer I
know it's not the same for you for a
human I can't imagine it gets any better
than said the girl who just had sex for
the first time also I'm not buying that
the ferocious vampire sex was so
mind-blowing to this virgin that she was
able to see past the pain and somehow
had fifty orgasms honeymoon let's play
chess I mean right no one will be seated
during the Bella and Edward play chess a
second time seat la la third time
blahblah chess is either gonna kill her
or change her and the Treaty says I say
Jacob any guy's not had this
conversation already where's it's just
some bull repeated argument you've been
having for several months now if Jacob
would just go find a girlfriend I don't
think this would be a problem did you
just get over it
it's not like you've imprinted on her
Jesus you kiss your mother with that
mouth okay props to Bella for being
imaginative with what she has on hand
but she is currently doing some kind of
cooking with restaurant takeout chicken
pieces peanut butter and yogurt in other
words what the fuck if she thinks she's
making obvious Salmonella catches a huge
break and hides behind Bella's
coincidental morning sickness is this
even possible
is this a serious question what if
Carlisle says no I sure I'm glad they
decided to show the exciting packing
scene with Edward doing his vampire it
sure beats not seeing a packing scene at
all and just going straight to the colon
house so we can figure out if Ella
really is pregnant right now we'd be
lost without this packing scene I tell
you thankfully for everyone in this
story this honeymoon island housekeeper
knows just enough legend to come in
handy during the human vampire pregnancy
no one thought was possible
Dovie continues to have a fantastic
sense of humor in the face of a
ridiculous plot sure
- easy what the this movie doesn't get
two sheets if I have any idea what's
taking place went I can't see it either
and I can't see Bella's future anymore
well that's convenient and applaud sense
even if it's inconvenient in a character
sense the fetus isn't good for Bella
save the word Alice baby it's just a
little baby abortion debate somehow
makes its way into part four of vampire
movie series an hour into this fucking
movie and we've had a wedding a sudden
pregnancy and now some wolf vampire
attention
that's an hour I'll never get back no I
can't figure out why he thinks you'd
listen to me you never have before
because you have constantly tried to get
in her pants and everything you've said
has directed her toward that goal and
even when you're being serious you flare
up in the wolf mode so fast that you
can't get a damn thought out without
being jacked towards from the shining
and when you die what was the point of
me loving you you loving him how was
that right for anyone first off it
wasn't right for anyone especially the
audience even if she lives asshole
second off who cares what her death
means to the love triangle it's like me
saying what was my purpose on earth if
the sun's going to blow up in four
billion years and this bike I'm wolf it
at home also time to wolf out and run
through the woods and review everything
that I've heard about Bella's condition
so far sometimes a good wolfing can
clear out your mind with this exercise I
once stumbled on a really good pasta
recipe so this should definitely figure
out Bella's vampire kid problem
so what we're all the members of Jacob
strong I'm currently in their wolf form
when they heard him howling were they
just kicking back me and wolfy just in
case someone gave him a call Jacob's
howl tell them all they needed to know
about the vampire kid and why did Jacob
tell them anything about it if he knew
the other wolves would be pissed and
want to kill Bella I mean even if he
thinks they'll only want the kid she
might be dead giving birth to it so what
was his endgame here you mean her choice
to get bring it on accident or her
choice to keep the baby this movie
really wants to talk about abortion does
it also I know there are a lot of people
out there who love Twilight we're not
gonna judge but you've gotta admit the
scene where the won't speak
telepathically in English to each other
is one of the stupidest things ever
committed to film I guess this means
something does that mean something will
someone please explain to me if that
means something okay no there's still
like six or so wolves here who do follow
Sam so can't they just tackle Jacob and
put him in wolf prison then plan their
attack why are they allowing this
because he yelled Jacob is rebelling
against his tribe and running into the
woods toward some unknown goal but still
took the time to get a proper human
shirt and pants for some reason ready
why did Jacob and Edward bother with
this weird long-distance supernatural
talk instead of just inviting him back
in was some other stupid power they
wanted to show off hey guys we can talk
normally at great distances Sam send you
Sam doesn't even know I left I was that
even possible
I think you just figured it out
seriously just now being unwanted isn't
exactly a new Saint sorry Ruby expects
me to remember some sort of backstory
about this character that was briefly
mentioned in the first movie and she
wasn't even introduced on screen until
the last movie and looking back at our
sins from that movie we didn't even
really know who she was then either so
Yahoo of course even though no one knows
what the hell is going on the Internet
is your one click stop to learn about
all that in one sitting these movies get
more and more annoying as they go along
but damned if I don't still really covet
that house Jesus Brad actually you are
the very definition of someone who can
live without it do you honestly think
that I could love it or even tolerated
Figg killed Wow Edward is the worst
father ever
and this kid isn't even born yet okay we
get it she looks awful make a decision
already why can't they just go ahead and
somehow c-section this baby out of her
at this point the baby is clearly so
strong it doesn't need to follow a
normal pregnancy protocol so why does
she feel like she needs to carry this
demon spawn to turn plus this watching
the USC Washington game
in 2011 when it extra didn't matter I
could only see the fetus baby maybe I
could figure out what it wants Jesus are
you serious
it wants out Simone negative latest -
Bella why didn't you try to do this
before why have you been sitting on this
until she looked like the zombie
apocalypse to finally suggest the idea
we put the blood in the Styrofoam cup of
the straw I'm seriously not able to stop
laughing about this taste oh my god the
suspense does taste bad or good I'm on
pins and tide
ah that's better yeah of course you are
the past 30 minutes of this movie had
been a thousand laps thought he was like
me but he Scotty's like you good pure
good and pure that's not like either of
you who loves you both and you also not
figure out that this he is a girl yet
since she's telling you everything else
so it's the last of it I realize they
didn't plan for a sudden vampire
pregnancy but Jesus they only had a few
days worth of blood on hand Carlyle
you're that enemy now Sam won't hesitate
you will be slaughtered
Jacob is so certain that Carlisle and
most of his vampire crew it would be
slaughtered in any fight with the wolves
I don't understand why Sam hasn't gone
full home-invasion on the Kaulitz in
fact why haven't the werewolves done
something like start a fire smoke them
out
this waiting game seems kind of stupid
to me also this is the most nothingness
ever happens this fucking movie I've
ever seen sister why are these wolves so
hell-bent on killing Bella's unborn
child again I mean it's at best - half
human half vampire thing right how is
that any scarier or more threatening
than the pack of vampires living in your
region you've already made peace with
Jacob sets up a distraction for the
other world so that Carlisle can run
through the woods with minimal werewolf
resistance but how's he know that when
he randomly walks into the woods enough
of the Wolves will come to talk to it
meanwhile these wolves hear something
but decide not to tell their wolf
counterparts that there's some going
down they might want to check out the
vampires we've seen in these movies are
like the flash but here these vampires
run kind of fast which is just slow
enough to get run down by werewolves now
how in the world did you - fuck this up
you played us any response well I'll
just run away
it's employ EJ Edward Jacob Oh jolly
good gum now what do you say Albus
Severus Potter old chap
[Applause]
Bella drops a cop and symbol what
happens
so with absolutely no doctor on the
premises a shot of morphine and an
attempted leap term murder abortion
everything's just cool now it's almost
like they were able to press
fast-forward to somehow avoid all
complications of vampire demon baby
birth also did somebody cut the
umbilical cord because I do not think
somebody cut the umbilical cord scene
intended to be touching contains super
bloody baby now ah yeah I better just go
straight to the CPR without checking or
breathing or her consciousness by the
way Jacob are you trained for this type
of thing
Jacob take the baby keep that away from
me yeah I only want to save the mother
of that creature I despise not the
creature itself dumbass I'll take her I
promise I'm okay okay girl who nearly
murdered this kid just one minute ago I
guess I can trust you since the plot
demands it I can't wait to give you my
baby what is that it's my fan which I
just happen to have lying around in a
syringe in this drawer I won't kill you
you deserve to live with this this seems
like the perfect time to have this
conversation
well Bella's life hangs in the balance
so did biting her wrists and ankles
cause this or did the giant needle full
of his venom do it why is the venom only
working now the venom no it needed to
act in such a way that it would be
dramatic for the audience alright if she
cool now also why is no one watching her
it's like Jasper and Alice decided to go
to the room enough sex because nothing
makes sex better than complicated birth
that could kill the mother digital baby
is absolutely fucking creepy
Jacob will now imprint on this CGI demon
baby which is still one of the creepiest
things about this series because it's
both parental and future mate stuff so
one can't help but wonder what it would
be like to protect a baby so that you
can forget in 18 years which just no one
should have to ponder that also Jacob
imprints on a fucking baby he just fell
in love with a baby I just want everyone
to know Jacob fell in love with a baby I
don't care if that means they'll just be
friends or he'll be her protector or
whatever the fuck they want to do to
justify this he just fell in love with a
baby also why why is this the way
imprinting works for Jacob does he not
have any control over it he had
absolutely crazy feelings for Bella but
it never happened now he sees a digital
child and he's suddenly wolf goo
yeah but imprinting as discussed by the
movies themselves have always suggested
that one day you will back oh there they
are
fresh from whatever movies that were
shooting other than this one to finally
get back into the action Carlisle and s
my ex machina everything so dark who
cares what happens also werewolves had
no idea they have sharp teeth and claws
opting to go with tackling and menacing
I mean these werewolves are awful
fighters and Jakob all but predicted a
slaughter a minute ago they're terrible
and stupid and I want to go home
werewolf imprints I can't be harmed it's
their most absolute law it is that's
dumb why not wolf not kill wolf or wolf
together strong stupid in printing
stupid Jakob somebody should write a law
about imprinting on vampire children too
late now stupid in pretty well some on
dead body needs the sandwich why is this
taking so long
a minute ago we saw the venom working
and it's magic bringing her back to life
now there's a waiting process like we're
at the DMV or some also when I was
turned it was nearly instantaneous wait
I may have said too much
previously on all the Twilight's I open
in cliffhanger cliche not Danis movie
has 13 minutes of credits this
mid-credits scene serves solely to tell
us that Carlisle at the Volturi Nobel
has been turned and that the Volturi are
still evil which enhances my enjoyment
of this movie and its credits negative
12th also to recap Bella Edward got
married played some chess had rough sex
resulting in a fetus everyone waited
around a long-ass time at the Cullen
house then the baby was born and Jacob
has some weird sexual non-sexual tied to
it the end Jesus that's like five pages
of script for fuck's sake
historic miss Thomas Thomas time ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes sometimes you
think you have true love and then you
catch the early flight home from San
Diego and a couple of new people jump
out of your bathroom blindfolded like a
goddamn magic show ready to double-team
your girlfriend and it stopped
crazy
[Applause]
everything's packed and ready to go my
bags packed
[Music]
[Applause]
five one-thousand breathe this is not
working Joe Jake over mutation it is the
key to our evolution it has enabled us
to evolve from a single-celled organism
into the dominant species on the planet
[Music]
you're looking at your Cutlass you're
looking at your things you're thinking
to yourself I don't know what to do man
I don't know how to kill the bunny with
fists you don't know how to kill the
bunny do you know what I mean